[Music]
as we head into the holiday weekend road
construction may give a lot of drivers a
holiday headache one area of concern the
15 at mesquite road construction
underway on both sides of the interstate
mary jane belliesa joins us live in
studio with where you can expect the
slowdown mary jane well kirsten you
should prepare for delays heading on the
northbound side of i-15 that's near
bunkerville and heading southbound on
the i-15 near exit
112. expect traffic delays if you're
heading out of town this weekend coming
up this labor day weekend is going to be
an issue so
just prepare people andrea meckley is
from logandale and makes frequent trips
to mesquite she wants to remind drivers
of the delays i work in mesquite two or
three days a week
and
we do volunteering up here and so you
know we're not going to stop going so we
kind of have to plan around the traffic
time the nevada department of
transportation says to expect single
lane closures heading north as crews are
repaving and resurfacing roads and are
placing down fiber lines to improve
traffic signals the closure has to
remain in place due to open trenches
stretching two miles long we hit
the
traffic and it's different each time we
can't even prepare because they've
changed the lane structure
daily it seems heidi sauer and her
family are driving from california to
colorado she's already hit traffic once
coming into las vegas and again heading
into mesquite be aware and definitely
slow down
watch in front of you
don't cut people off
a drainage project has also closed down
one lane from the i-15 that's heading
south the project is expected to wrap up
next week but not in time for labor day
now the northbound construction project
is expected to end in about three weeks
in late september